[Music]
foreign
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that promises to let you sit
and watch public domain cartoons for as
long as you want provided you stab that
subscribe button right in the eye now
I'm not a man with a whole lot of free
time between launching new channels
subscribe to style Theory by the way
writing and rewriting FNAF timelines
being a father and you know just just
trying to have an actual life things can
get pretty darn busy but in what little
free time I've had lately I've been
scrolling through the tick tocks to see
what's hip with the kiddos and what I've
seen has been nothing but pages and
pages of Pedro Pascal fan cams do not
make fan cams of school staff oh you
can't stop me Pedro I can and I will
[Music]
Adore Me
but once I scroll past those I was
inundated by something far less
aesthetic and much more scary a
terrifying new horror movie called
Skinnamarink everything I saw Harold did
this thing as the scariest movie ever
because some people are saying this is
literally the most disturbing thing
they've ever seen and after watching it
yes and based on the trailer alone I was
home in this house in
understand
ladies and gentlemen we have reached
Peak analog horror so intrigued and a
little bit scared I did what any normal
person would do I sat down at 9am on a
Wednesday morning with two of my
employees to watch through this puppy
and boy was it controversial one of them
rated at Nate's the other rated it a
zero and said it didn't even deserve to
be called a movie and honestly I can't
really blame him for his opinion five
minutes in and it's immediately clear
why this thing is gonna be a divisive
movie it's about 100 minutes of staring
at dark walls and grainy hallways while
people whisper in the background it is
not for everyone as for my opinion I can
tell you that it was probably the most
active movie watching experience that
I've ever had with my eyes constantly
scanning the frame questioning whether
what I was seeing was a Shadow Monster
or just artifacting of the camera I
wasn't just passively watching a movie I
was having to solve each and every frame
trying to understand what exactly I was
looking at tldr it worked for me I
really enjoyed it but not only is
skinnamarink a visually challenging
movie it also is a narratively
challenging one the story as it's
presented to us is about two young
children Kaylee and Kevin who wake up in
the middle of the night to find that
their parents have disappeared along
with all the House's doors and windows
and so the kids in the movie respond
like any normal child would do in this
sort of situation they Park themselves
right in front of that TV and start
binge watching some old school copyright
neutral cartoons pretty soon though
things get worse as they begin to
realize that they're not alone inside
the house is a formless demon who makes
the kids do horrific things like
walk up the stairs and
walk up the stairs again he is a very
cardiovascular ghost oh yeah also put a
knife in your eye
we don't actually see anything but the
sudden switch to implied violence is
just incredibly jarring bit by bit
things get progressively worse for our
young Duo toys begin sticking to the
ceiling Night Lights get unplugged the
toilets disappear man this demon is
ruthless the eye thing yeah that was
brutal but making them poop in buckets
that's just cruel eventually Kaylee
disappears leaving the four-year-old
Kevin alone in a house that has
literally and figuratively turned upside
down as the movie ends we see this image
stating 572 days which is super random
because up to this point there really
hasn't been any clear focus on the
passage of time and then you have this
brutally long pull out shot that lasts
almost two consecutive minutes just
really milking it for that watch time
aren't they on an unrelated note did I
mention the director for this thing
gotta start on YouTube I see you I know
what you're doing
there's a bit more screaming and
whispering and blood before the movie
ultimately ends with a blurry figure
Fading Into frame telling Kevin to
and that's about it clear as Crystal
right well yeah actually kinda on the
surface it seems like just another
spooky ghost movie but looking at it
that way actually leaves a lot of
unanswered questions what was the
monster why did everything disappear
where did the parents go what is the
significance of 572 days and what does
that ending actually mean in short this
movie is an open invite for theorists to
solve you know what I think I cracked it
what seems like a simple ghost story is
actually a tragedy terribly sad story
about loss grief and family trauma all
told from the perspective of a
four-year-old child everything we see
the film feels like a paranormal
situation right we hear voices we see
things stuck to the ceiling we have
doors disappearing and we have this
constant grain and Distortion what could
cause all of this if not a demon well
let's just start from the very beginning
the movie kicks off with a seemingly
random event where Kevin falls down some
stairs in the middle of the night we see
a series of clips of Kevin stealing
blankets from his closet sitting up on
top of the stairs and then we get an
upside down shot of the bottom of the
stairs after hearing a loud thud this is
Then followed up by his dad on the phone
following but Kevin fell down the stairs
and hit his head seems pretty cut and
dry Kevin falls down some stairs and
hits his head there's just one problem
with that this incident is never
mentioned again it is completely
arbitrary for everything that comes
afterwards it goes nowhere and nothing
comes of it why would the director be
showing us this then why is it the first
event of the movie well I suspect it's
because this is the real incident that
incites everything we see happen
afterward the fall sends Kevin into a
coma and everything we see from that
point onward in the movie are the real
world events being filtered and process
through his unconscious condition now
let me immediately say that I know how
lame coma theories are you can make
anything fit into a coma or dream theory
because there's no logic in these things
anything can be bent to be a piece of
evidence there is a reason that across
the 1012 theories that I've written
across the last decade only one of them
has claimed that everything was a dream
and that's because I only pull him out
when I think that that's the author's
true intent and with skinamarink I am
convinced that this is the right
interpretation obviously we just talked
about the inciting incident of a head
injury but there is so so much more here
across the entirety of the movie there
are three random details of this
supposed haunting that stood out to me
as unusual the missing toilets the
request to stick a knife in Kevin's eye
and the marker of 572 days so let's just
go back and Tackle these one at a time
first let's just take a look at the
basic concept of the film itself well
the idea of doors and windows
disappearing from a house makes for a
creepy paranormal setup what doesn't fit
quite as well is The Disappearance of
the toilets the lack of doors and
windows I totally get you're trapped
inside of a situation that you can't
escape from you're at the mercy of the
demon but the toilets I mean why would a
paranormal entity do that it's either a
big troll or this isn't actually a ghost
that we're dealing with so let's just
assume that everything after Kevin falls
down the stairs and hits his head takes
place in a hospital well if that's truly
the case then the disappearing toilets
would be the reality of his current
situation he's no longer physically
going to the bathroom and toilets
anymore depending on the policy of the
hospital he's in he's likely using a
bedpan diapers or a rectal catheter to
excrete his waist this would also
explain the disappearing doors and
windows that form the core of this
movie's plot on one hand it's symbolic
of Kevin now being trapped inside his
own mind with no Escape that's why near
the end of the movie when he asks to
watch something happy we see visions of
a door it's a moment or a chance of
Escape but the disappearing doors and
windows could also literally be the
hospital room around him a
claustrophobic space that's blocked off
by curtains in fact look closer at your
typical hospital room and what do you
see in each one a TV sitting in front of
the patient playing all day every day
and what do we see in skinamarink a TV
as a constant presence throughout
everything in the film so much of this
movie is spent sitting in front of a TV
specifically public domain cartoons It's
gotta mean something right it does these
cartoons are the entire plot of the
movie if you take a closer look at the
cartoons that play and win they play
they seem to be telling us the real
story of what's happening in the movie
one of the first cartoons we see after
Kevin's accident is this a baby bird
being shot out of the sky and appearing
dead this cartoon is the song of the
birds from 1935 except there's a Twist
here if you watch beyond what they show
in skinamarink when the birds go to bury
the baby's body he wakes up and everyone
celebrates this cartoon I suspect is
representative of Kevin's injury he's
the baby bird who is knocked unconscious
this clip even plays after the kids ask
the question
it's because mom thinks that her baby
bird is dead or maybe just close to
death the second major cartoon we see is
the cobweb hotel from 1936 where two
newlywed flies watch helplessly as a
Young Fly is trapped inside a monstrous
spider's bed of webs they then have to
fight to escape from the spider now this
could very easily be symbolic of Kevin
and Kaylee fighting against the monster
that has him trapped inside the house
but it could also be Kevin's parents
forced to watch their son trapped inside
of a hospital bed unable to escape
considering that the two newlywed flies
are adults I suspect it's the second
explanation the third major cartoon
reference we get is to 1931's Bimbo's
initiation this one we don't actually
see but I was able to recognize the
audio from research we did years ago
when we did our bendy and the ink
machine episode about rubber hose
animation
the cow
in this one bimbo falls down a sewer
only to be locked in a prison of
inescapable false doors all while the
World Turns Upside Down around him a
character falls down winds up trapped in
a place without doors and everything
Turns Upside Down why even have a movie
skinamarink you told us everything we
needed to know right there and in the
final cartoon 1939's Presto Chango we
see this clip of a dog that's being shot
in the eye again sound familiar
the cartoons are telling the story of
Kevin's life and why are they always on
why are they always playing because he's
sitting in a hospital room stuck in
front of a TV but with all that said
let's look a bit closer at the eye bit
it's one of the very few moments of
implied violence in the movie so
obviously it's gonna stand out as
important but again why why this of all
things just to shock us again I don't
think so let's take a look back at what
caused Kevin to fall down the stairs in
the first place
everybody
Kaylee says he was sleepwalking huh
sleepwalking hallucinations eye pain it
doesn't take Derek Shepherd to know
what's going on with this one Kevin has
a brain tumor and yeah that was a Gray's
Anatomy reference for any of you under
the age of 45. I suspect Kevin was
suffering from a tumor on the frontal
lobe of his brain thereby causing him to
sleepwalk hallucinate and ultimately
fall down the stairs in fact brain
tumors are the most common form of solid
tumor inside of children affecting about
5 000 in the U.S every year but I
suspect happened here was that the brain
tumor caused his sleepwalking and
subsequent fall and while the fall
itself might have resulted in a minor
injury considering what we hear from
Dad's phone call the subsequent hospital
visit or the damage that the fall caused
made the tumor issue worse but Kevin
ultimately winding up in a coma shortly
thereafter so what does all of that have
to do with knives and eyes well I don't
think that it was just any knife we're
talking about here I think what's going
on is a surgical procedure one way to
remove tumors from the frontal lobe of
the brain is to perform a procedure
known as a supraorbital keyhole
craniotomy a type a brain surgery where
they go in through you guessed it the
eye it's minimally invasive and it's an
easier way to reach the frontal lobe to
remove the tumor which is why Kevin
feels like he's being stabbed in the eye
with a knife this would also explain
another weird detail that we see towards
the end of the film at the top of the
movie we get a montage of various Family
Photos hanging on the wall at the end we
get a similar Montage but this time
everyone is missing their head or the
faces have been weirdly distorted this
would be the result of a condition known
as prosopagnosia also known as face
blindness where you cannot recognize
people's faces it's a symptom that often
appears in patients with brain tumors
this leads us then to the ending of the
film where we see blood being sprayed on
the floor over and over all while we
hear screaming in the background and the
repeating music from the Presto Chango
cartoon the one where the dog gets shot
in the eye if you turn on the closed
captions the first round of screaming we
hear is captioned as child crying thank
you closed caption people for not naming
him the crying child I just can't
rewrite the damn FNAF timeline again the
next round of screaming though is
credited as older child prize this scene
I suspect is Kevin being operated on
over and over over a prolonged period
that's why the blood spills on the
carpet repeatedly but the music is
pulled from the cartoon that references
his eye pain and why the subtitles
differentiate child and older child it
is two years of Kevin in a coma
undergoing procedures like this as
doctors try and repeatedly fail at
removing the tumor that's endangering
his life how do I know it's been two
years the 572 days marker that we see in
the film's final act at no point in the
movie is there ever any sort of emphasis
on the passage of time and yet for some
reason the film decides to call out this
little fact as important I suspect this
is how long Kevin's in a coma before he
finally passes on they're calling out
the final day of his life and he's being
ushered into the Afterlife by his mother
you see at the end of the surgery
sequence Kevin cries out for his mommy
he's looking to her for help but she
doesn't come it's only in the final shot
of the movie that she arrives this
blurry nightmare fuel faceless
homunculus in the back yeah that right
there is his mommy and she's telling him
to go to sleep to pass on on Kevin is
being released from his pain and the
movie ends but why is his mom here now
well to understand that we have to zoom
out you see this whole time I've been
trying to prove to you that Kevin's in a
coma and I feel real good about that
conclusion and the evidence that we've
presented so far but in the process I've
been having to ignore what's happening
around Kevin specifically around his
parents this whole movie's premise is
that Kaylee and Kevin's dad disappears
one night notice that I say Dad
specifically and not parents that's
actually in the official movie's
description so why is Dad gone and where
is Mom well we hear mentions of Mom very
sparingly early on we hear the question
shortly afterward we spent some quality
time with Mom in one of the most
disturbing scenes of the movie Kaylee is
brought up to her parents room by the
mysterious voice her dad is sitting
hunched on the bed Kaylee looks away for
a moment and suddenly her dad is gone
replaced with her mom after a
half-hearted hey we're getting a divorce
kiddo style talk
we hear a very clear snapping sound
this paired with the repeated imagery we
see of dowels hanging from the ceiling
leads me to believe that their mother
unfortunately took her own life she was
so distraught over Kevin's condition
that she cries repeatedly the family
gets a divorce and then she ultimately
ends it all this works with why we hear
Kaylee asking about the crying and why
at a later point when asked about mom
she says
that's also why moms at the end of the
movie helping to ease Kevin into the
Afterlife is because she's there too
she's also dead Okay so we've
established why we don't see Mom but
then what explains dad's disappearance
well Kevin's dad just doesn't come to
visit anymore we know that Kevin's been
in his hospital bed for 572 days based
on the text from the end of the movie
572 days in a coma almost two years dad
just can't do it anymore he disappears
there's only one person left who wants
to come and see Kevin who will sit with
him and watch cartoons with him on the
hospital TV who still talks to him
Kaylee but even she eventually succumbs
to the monster
foreign
even she gives up to the Hopeless
darkness that Kevin won't wake up her
mouth was stolen she disappears too just
like everyone else one of the final
shots of the movie is a return to the
stare banister upside down the way Kevin
saw it after his fall this provides our
story a complete bookend we return back
to where everything began the house at
this point has figuratively and
literally been turned upside down and
now appears to Kevin in the way that he
saw it after his tumble Skidamarink is a
tragic tale of a family broken apart of
a loving father mother and sister forced
to confront an unforgiving and unending
medical condition and the little boy
who's trapped in a hospital bed with no
way out trying to understand it all
through the grainy dark filter of his
unconscious State even the name
skinamarink tells us exactly what this
movie's about it's the name of a
children's nursery rhyme All About Love
skinamarink A Dinka dink skinamarink a
do I love you I love you in the morning
and in the afternoon I love you in the
evening and underneath the Moon that is
the central theme of the film love and
that's also the true horror of this film
The there are just some things that love
can't overcome some things that are so
dark so ceaseless that they swallow all
that love away oh this film really hits
so much harder than I expected a tick
tock hyped Art House horror filmed too
so if you have kids give them a hug if
you are a kid go give your parents a hug
we gotta counteract the horribly sad
with something wholesome but hey if you
ever find yourself trapped in a dream
house with disappearing doors and
windows you're probably gonna want some
food delivered to you well with the
sponsor of today's video hellofresh that
dream can become a reality hellofresh
has 40 weekly recipes for you to choose
from so we always get something new and
exciting and if you're on a low calorie
carb smart or veggie focused diet or
just a really picky eater not only are
there plenty of options for you you can
also customize your meals switching out
proteins and sides or even adding
proteins to a veggie dish seven I have a
lot going on so getting delicious food
delivered directly to our doorstep so we
can skip a trip to the grocery store it
is a game changer it lets us spend more
time focused on decoding the stories of
strange indie horror movies and less
time deciding on what we want for dinner
hello fresh also helps us cut back on
takeout and delivery the cost to which
can add up real fast I mean why go out
to get restaurant quality food when
delicious food can just show up at your
doorstep and you get the satisfaction of
making it fresh for yourself one of the
meals we got recently were these
delicious monterey jack burgers with
potato wedges and it felt so great
getting hands on cooking these things
hellofresh sends pre-portioned
ingredients and easy to follow recipes
that let us make this incredible
hancooked dinner without having to think
about meal planning or meal prep and
that is awesome even better all the
ingredients in this meal were super
fresh with less than seven days between
these things being on a farm to getting
on our doorstep if you want to try your
hand at cooking your own meals with a
ton of different options go to
hellofresh.com and use the code filmfare
65 for 65 off plus free shipping once
again that's hellofresh.com with the
code
f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-y65 or you can just
click the link down in the description
if you don't want to type all that out
that is 65 off and free shipping not too
shabby thanks again to hellofresh for
sponsoring today's video and as all
always remember it's all just a theory a
film Theory and cut